Bud Light has just become the latest
company to sponsor Dylan Mulvaney you
know that regular Bud Light consumer
guy getting off a hard day at work over
in construction or something he comes
home and what does he want to do he
wants to crack open a can with a
transvestite on it is that right I'm not
so sure about that I really lucked out
on the whole Bud Light Dylan Mulvaney
controversy because I have never really
cared for Bud Light all that much at all
and in fact my preferred canned alcohol
white Claw is already so gay that it
does not need to prove its LGBT Bona
fides by sponsoring a transvestite so
I'm totally fine here I will continue to
enjoy my delicious canned black cherry
and mango hard Seltzer drinks